- Hallo. - Guten Tag.
- Bitte schön?
- Ich hätte gerne Salami.
- Ja.
- Können Sie mir da eine
bestimmte Sorte empfehlen?
- Ja. Dann gehen wir mal hier rüber.
Möchten Sie die Salami für auf
eine Pizza zum Beispiel
oder zum Baguette oder zum Abendbrot?
- Genau. Eher so zum Abendbrot.
- Zum Abendbrot. Es gibt wunderbar,
wenn Sie was Milderes möchten,
die klassische deutsche Salami.
Es gibt eine, sehr lecker,
die italienische Mailänder Salami.
Das ist eine spanische Baguettesalami,
die hat auch einen Pfefferrand,
dadurch ist sie was kräftiger. Auch sehr
lecker ist die französische Baguettesalami,
auch mild im Geschmack. Auch sehr
lecker ’ne Trüffelsalami.
- Aha. Okay.
- Können Sie auch gerne mal etwas
probieren, wenn Sie möchten.
- Ja, gerne.
- Trüffelsalami? Ja. Probieren wir die mal.
Hol ich ein Stück raus.
- Danke schön.
- Gerne.
- Ja, schmeckt sehr interessant. Ich denke,
ich würd mal diese Trüffelsalami probieren.
Die schmeckt sehr gut
und sehr interessant.
- Ja, ist mal was anderes.
- Genau. Dann hätte ich gerne
150 Gramm von der Trüffelsalami.
- 152 [Gramm] in Ordnung?
- Ja, das ist in Ordnung.
- Dann sind wir bei 152 [Gramm].
- Alles klar.
- Außerdem noch einen Wunsch?
- Das wäre es. Danke.
- Danke schön.
- Entschuldigung.
- Bitte sehr!
- Könnten Sie mir verraten,
wo ich Mais finde?
- Natürlich, kommen Sie mit,
zeig ich Ihnen.
- Ja, danke schön.
Hier sind wir auf jeden Fall
bei den Gemüsekonserven,
und hier finden Sie den Mais
einmal in der großen Dose
und hier vorne einmal in
der kleinen Dose.
- Alles klar. Vielen Dank.
- Bitte sehr.